There is a lot of pressure that comes along
with being famous.
And existing in the public eye 24/7 can take
its toll on even the most level-headed entertainers.
Especially if they’re tied to a hugely successful
franchise.
Constant interruptions and autograph requests
can get tiresome, but most people argue that’s
just part of the job.
And as with all jobs, some people are just
better at it than others.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Actors Who Are
Terrible To Their Fans.
Christian Bale
Christian Bale avoids the spotlight as much
as possible when he’s not working.
And has said that he aims to maintain a boundary
between his professional life and his private
one.
But that’s pretty hard to do once everyone
knows you’re Batman.
Even harder after someone claiming to be your
ex-publicist writes a tell-all book about
what a jerk you supposedly are.
And that’s exactly what happened.
The book claims that when the actor was approached
by some young fans at a restaurant, they left
his table in tears.
Apparently having received a harsh lecture
about manners.
And again we are reminded that Christian Bale
does not like to be interrupted.
Ewan McGregor
For an actor, being cast in a Star Wars movie
should feel like an honor, because it is.
The franchise has a gigantic following worldwide,
and it’s a great opportunity to perform
in front of millions of people.
So when Ewan McGregor was given the chance
to play young Obi-Wan Kenobi, he took it.
The films received a ton of attention and,
understandably, the actor was suddenly bombarded
by people who wanted his autograph.
When he was asked about his relationship with
the Star Wars audience, McGregor said that
he hadn’t met any fans, only “wankers”
looking to make money by selling his signature
on the internet.
He explained that his issue is with people
who take advantage of the franchise’s fans
in this way.
Still though, if there were any real fans
mixed in with the “wankers” he’s referring
to, they’re probably pretty devastated.
Robert Pattinson
If you’re going to sign on to a five movie
franchise, it’s a good idea to make sure
you enjoy playing your character.
Because you’re going to be spending a lot
of time in their shoes.
But this is something Robert Pattinson completely
overlooked when he agreed to play the big
screen version of Edward, hunky vampire from
the Twilight book series.
The movies were incredibly successful, and
brought in over three billion dollars worldwide.
A lot of that is thanks to a loyal fanbase
who followed the story from book to screen.
But when the actor took a look at the first
book in preparation, he said it read like
something that got written by a crazy person
and published by mistake.
As a further blow to Team Edward, Pattinson
has also talked about how much he disliked
the character- and compared the sparkly vamp
with an axe murderer.
Oh, and the nickname “R-Patz”?
He hates that too.
Simon Pegg
With multiple franchises under his belt, the
lovable Simon Pegg has become a household
name.
And when he took the role as Scotty in Star
Trek, people were psyched.
The second film, Star Trek Into Darkness,
wasn’t as well received as the first.
When some Trekkies left the theatre unimpressed,
they did what most people do: took to the
internet.
Asserting that the movies were straying too
far outside the canon, an online poll was
created and Into Darkness was voted the worst
Star Trek movie of all time.
Ignoring the fact that the participant pool
was probably biased, reporters brought it
up in countless interviews.
And Simon Pegg was tired of hearing about
it.
The actor argued that people who didn’t
like the movie only felt that way because
it was no longer exclusive to a niche market-
not because it was bad.
Finally, he ended his response with a big
“fuck you” to the haters.
Jesse Eisenberg
Have you ever said something that you tried
to take back?
A comment that only sounded worse the more
you tried to explain it?
Jesse Eisenberg has.
During promotion for Batman v Superman: Dawn
of Justice, the actor swung by Comic Con.
The convention is a place where fans from
all over the world meet to get up close and
personal with their favorite heroes.
Usually everyone involved has a positive experience,
but Eisenberg couldn’t wait to get the hell
out of there.
In an interview afterward, he compared Comic
Con to a “genocide”.
And after someone pointed out how offensive
that was, he tried to backpedal.
Explaining that his senses were being overloaded,
he was scared by the fans, and that he had
used hyperbole to get his point across.
No apology though.
Shia LaBeouf
Somewhere between Louis Stevens and now, Shia
LaBeouf started acting a little wacky.
And thanks to social media, everyone can talk
about it instantly.
There have been reports of the actor picking
fights with fans, then threatening to pull
a knife on anyone who intervenes.
He’s been carted away by the cops on more
than one occasion, and has had public arguments
with girlfriends in the past.
Some people are wondering if it’s all an
elaborate joke or symptoms of something more
serious.
Fellow actor James Franco has written about
LaBeouf, saying he wasn’t sure if his behavior
was part of an art project, or the result
of a nervous breakdown.
Either way, he encouraged the actor not to
use up all the good he’s built with fans.
Gwyneth Paltrow
Gwyneth Paltrow was born into a successful
Hollywood family, and had access to a lot
of opportunities that most of us could only
dream of.
So when she claimed that her work-life balance
as a mother was harder to maintain than “regular
moms”, more than a few eyebrows were raised
in response.
The so-called regular moms were shocked at
how flippantly condescending Paltrow’s follow-up
remarks were to working mothers everywhere.
Maybe the starlet’s sheltered life really
has disconnected her from the realities facing
modern parents, but she’s not apologizing.
In fact, the actress responded in a post on
her blog, and chided the protesters for “projecting
their issues” on to her.
Some people just don’t know how to apologize.
Alec Guinness
It seems the Obi-Wan Kenobis of the world
are kind of a grumpy bunch.
And one legendary tale regarding the actor
who played him has been circulating for years.
The story- detailed in Alec Guinness’ book-
says that a young fan and his mom approached
the actor and when the child told Obi-Wan
that he’d seen the movie over a hundred
times, Guinness made him promise to never
watch it again.
Guinness’ version has the story ending with
the child running away crying, but a different
perspective was brought to light from someone
claiming to be the boy from the story.
The alternate account says the actor was actually
quite charming, and that they all shared a
laugh after Guinness suggested the boy abstain
from Star Wars.
The author is also adamant that he never cried
either, he just had something in his eye.
Tobey Maguire
Peter Parker is usually a pretty nice guy,
and Tobey Maguire plays him well.
So it’s only natural to assume that he’d
be nice in real-life too, right?
Well when one fan tried to take a picture
with the actor, it didn’t go as planned.
In a video that spread across the internet
like wildfire.
Maguire turns and smacks the camera out of
the fan’s hand.
The actor struts away like it never happened
and disappears into a crowd of security people.
While everyone’s entitled to some personal
space, the reaction is a little over the top.
And considering how disappointing Spider-Man
3 was, it’s amazing anyone even wanted his
picture.
Jared Leto
Being in the business for a long time sometimes
makes entertainers jaded.
Instead of being grateful for their fans,
they come to resent them.
And sometimes that comes out in really weird,
really public ways.
Before Jared Leto landed the role as The Joker
in Suicide Squad, he was acting in movies
like Dallas Buyers Club and Requiem for a
Dream.
In addition, Leto is also the frontman for
the band 30 Seconds To Mars.
And it was at one of their concerts where
someone took a video of the singer beating
a fan in the head with his microphone.
Shortly after, another video surfaced of him
doing the same thing to someone else at a
different show.
He also recently made headlines for sending
some messed up gifts to his Suicide Squad
cast mates.
It seems like no matter where he goes, Jared
Leto is pissing people off.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other actors who are terrible
to their fans?
Join the conversation in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.